[موسيقى]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
نشره الخامسه من العربيه التي نستهلها
بابرز العنوي
اشتعالوا جبهه دوناتس وحربوا شوارع في
سوليدار وكيف تعزز قواتها في الدم بس
لتجنب سقوط
الشعر
الاعدامات في ايران وقائد الحرس الثوري
يصف الاحتجاجات بانها حرب عالميه على بلاد
وشرطه الابرازيليه تفض اعتصاما لانصار فول
سانارو في برازيليا وتزيل خيامه
بريطانيا تسارع لتسريح المرضى من
المستشفيات لتخفيف ازمه نقص الاسر
اهلا بكم الى نشره الخامسه حرب شوارع تدور
بين القوات الروسيه والاوكرانيه في
سوليدار واشتعاله للجبهه على طول خط
التماس في دوناتس
فقد اعلن انفصلي لروسيا السيطره على بلده
الواقعه بالقرب شمال
تزويد القوات الاوكرانيه في الدم بس حيث
تمر عبر هذه المدينه شبكه من الطرق والسكك
الحديد
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اعلنت ان قواتها
تواصل عملياتها الهجوميه على طول خط
التماس في الدوناتس واشارت في بيان لها
الا ان العمليات الهجوميه تتقدم باتجاه
سوليدار وبخمود حيث تدور معارك عنيفه مع
القوات الاوكرانيه
واضافت ايضا انه تم استهدافه 89 وحده
مدفعيه تابعه للقوات الاوكرانيه
واعتراضها 10 صواريخ من طراز هيمارس
مسؤوله في وزاره الدفاع الروسيه وصف وضع
الجنود الاوكرانيين بصعب
ويعتبروا بقاء القوات الاوكرانيه في
سوليدار وبخمت امرا حيويا بالنسبه للكلاب
وذلك للحفاظ على حائضها الدفاعي الذي يحمي
سلوفيا
في منطقه الدمبس شرقيه اوكرانيا وما
تزلاني تحت سيطره تركيا مع الاشاره الى ان
احد اهداف روسيا المعلنه منذ بدايه الحرب
هي السيطره على منطقه الدم بس بالكامل
من جهتها اشارت نائبه وزير الدفاع
الاوكرانيه هانا مليار عبر قناتي على
تليغرام الى ان الوضع الصعب في سوليدار
حاليا مضيفه ان روسيا تشنها هجمات عبر
جيشها ومرتزقه فاجنر على حد قوليها
ورغم القتال العنيف شرقا قال الرئيس
الاوكراني غولدن انه لا يتوقع ان يتقدم من
روسيا كبير عبر الخطوط الاوكرانيه كما وعد
قوته بمزيد من التعزيزات
اوكرانيا اعلنت ايضا انها تعزز قواتها في
منطقه الدومبه الشرقيه البلاد وتصد
الهجمات المستمره التي تشنها مجموعه
الروسيه الخاصه على بخمه وبلدات اخرى هنا
واضافت السلطات الاوكرانيه ان التعزيزات
ارسلت الى سوليدار بالقرب من باخر مشيره
الى ان روسيا اقمت وحدات اكثر احترافيه من
مجموعه فاجنر
وسائل الاعلام البريطانيه نقلت عن مصادر
بالحكومه امكانيه ارسال دبابات بريطانيه
الى اوكرانيا لاول مره منذ دلاع الحرب
وافادت المصادر بان الحكومه تدرس ارسالها
عشر دبابات باطراز تشالنجر 2 على امل ان
يدفع ذلك الحلفاء لان يحذواها
وتعتبر تشالنجر 2 دبابه قتاليه رئيسيه في
الجيش البريطاني وتتمكن من اصابه ثمانيه
اهداف
مختلفه في الدقيقه الواحده
وتتميزوا بنظام الكتروني للتحكم
لمزيد من المتابعه اذهب الى دونيسك انضم
الي من هناك مراسل العربيه رائد الاخبار
ومنكياج الصحفي محمد البابا ابدا معك رائد
اخر اخبار المعارك المتواصله سواء في
سوليدار او في المحيط بخمرات رائد
يعني طالب ام المعارك كما سميت مع بدايه
الحمله العسكريه حيث قيل بان المعركه
الكبرى ستكون في دانيسكو في الشرق
الاوكراني بالفعل ما نشهده الان هو عوده
الى المحور الشرقي وتحتدم المعارك بل تصبح
مستعره بالفعل همم هنا في ذلك خلال 24
ساعه الماضيه قليلين واصابتين عدا عن
الدمار في البناء التحتيه والمباني
السكنيه قبل قليل امراه وايضا اصابه واحده
هنا بالقرب منه باحد يعني باحداث وصفات
الاوكرانيه همم المحور المتاخم لدانيا
مستعر جدا ومعارك ضاريه في ماركا الاكمال
السيطره على المدينه من قبل قوات مواليه
لروسيا قوات ثانيه لكن كما استلفت المحور
الاهم
حول اداره
تتجمع
القوات الخاصه ان كانت اول القوات
الشيشانيه او حتى الخطوات الشعبيه القادمه
من لوغانس قوات لوغانسكي الشعبيه تتقدم من
شمال لابد من التفكير دائما بالموقع
الجغرافي لمدينه باقبوط وما حولها مدينه
باق متقع من ناحيه الشماليه من مقاطعه
دينيسيا اي متاخمه لوجان حيث اخر معاقل
الجيش الاوروني كانت في الاسانس اذا تذكر
طالب همم انسحب الجيش
همم بدا الطوق كاملا من قبل القوات الخاصه
حيث قدمت من وسط دنيا تصل الى الناحيه
الجنوبيه من المدينه
الطوق من الناحيه الشرقيه وتبقى الناحيه
الشماليه همم كان ليس هناك همم الا من
تطوير سيلدر مع باخبط وبالفعل طوقت القوه
الخاصه المختلفه في دلاليه على مرتبطه مع
روسيا طوقت مدينه مع سيدار من ثلاثه نواحي
طيب
انا انا
ساسالك بعد قليل عن حدود السيطره الروسيه
سواء على سوليدار او على همم ولكن ثاني
ينتقل الى محمد البابا في كيف محمد اخر
المعلومات المتوفره لديك عن معارك الدم بس
وهل بدات كيف من خلال تصريحات مسؤليها
تسلم بان معركه سوليدار ميؤوس منها
ولكن يعني بحسب وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه
وهيئه الاركان والمعلومات التي اتت يعني
قبل حوالي 15 الى 20 دقيقه ان الجيش
الاوكراني والان يعني الان يوجد في سوليدر
قائد العمليات في ثلث في ذلك
المحورس وهو الذي يقود الان العمليات في
سوريا لماذا كما قال رائد كانت القوات
الروسيه تحاول التقدم لمحاصره سوليدار
ودفع القوات الاوكرانيه للتراجع من سوريا
وتقدمت القوات الروسيه الى منطقه باخ
موسكي ودخلتها يعني في ليله امس لكن الجيش
الاوكراني وعندما وصلت
معه وحدات قتاليه قامت فورا بعمليه اكثر
في منطقه يعني
فقط
في تلك المنطقه
همم كانت القوه الروسيه تحاول يعني ان
تكون بطوق من الجهه الشماليه الشرقيه
والجنوبيه يكون
درجه وبحسب المعلومات من غرفه العمليات
داخل منطقه يعني باخمود ان الجيش
الاوكراني استطاع قتل 177 دروس الان
متواجدين في الارض في ساحه يعني في شوارع
وفي احياء منطقه همم
بخموسكي وايضا 186 جندي روسي مصابين حتى
يعني يقال في الاوساط العسكريه الاوكرانيه
ان الجيش الاوكراني الاسعاف تحاول اسعاف
هؤلاء الجنود والقبض عليهم المصابين الان
في باكم وايضا الجيش الروسي كشف وضربته
المدفعيه ولا عنيفه على بخمه لمنع تقدم
وارسال قوات اوكرانيه من باخمه
لان هدف القوات الروسيه في محور في اول
مرحله محاصره وطرد القوات الاوكرانيات من
سوليدار». لذلك يعني من الشعب السيطره
بشكل كامل فوق الارض عليها لانه هناك
خنادق والجيش الاوكراني خلال فتره سته او
سبعه اشهر ثمانيه حصلت تلك المنطقه
بشكل كبير جدا هناك اخذ ولد تقدم القوات
بس انا انا محمد انا ما ردت تساؤلي لانه
وزيره الدفاع الاوكرانيه قالت ان المعارك
في سوليدار صعبه جدا داني اعود الى رائد
رائد في حال سقطت سوليدار وربما باخمد
بايدي القوات الروسيه ما الذي يعنيه ذلك
بالنسبه الى الروس
ني انا اتحدث
التي تكلم عنها همم زميلي محمد بالفعل
هناك تقدم عسكري قوي للقوات الروسيه من
الناحيه الشماليه وهنا حرب شوارع قتال
شوارع داخل سوليدار حتى لو كانت القوات
الاخرانيه همم يعني تضخ او تمد همم
المقاتلين هناك بالجنود فاننا المعارك
ضاريه وهناك تقدم لجانب الروسي في حال
سيطره قوات الروسيه بدايه على سوريا
من ثلاث جهات وتركت المخرج الغربي من
الناحيه الغربيه فقط والاله العسكريه ال-
ثقيله نقصد جماعه الصواريخ المدافع
الروسيه تقصد باستمرار مواقع عسكريه لجيش
الاوكراني داخل وتدفعهم للانسحاب وفي حال
سيطره جيش الروسيه على باقيته هذا لن الا
خلال شهر او شهرين على الاقل لان الفعل
يعني همم يعني الحصون والانفاق التي همم
يعني مكن نفسه الجيش الاوكراني داخل هذه
المدينه عميقه جدا وكثيره ولا يستطيع
الجيش الروسي يتغطيها الا حظر همم يعني
مده زمنيه شهر او شهرين لكن في حال
السيطره خلال فتره على مدينه باك تكون
الابواب فتحت للمدن الكبرى وهي كرامه
الاخبار شكرا جزيلا لك شكرا ايضا
للصحفي محمد البابا على كل هذه المتابعه
هذا وحضر التقارير استخباراتيه بريطانيه
من استخدام روسيا اسلحه حديثه لتعزيز
قواتها او قواتها الناريه في الحرب ضد
اوكرانيا ابرزها استخدام طائرات من طراز
سوخوي 57
تريدوا الحرب في اوكرانيا سيناريوهات
جديده فمع استمرار الوصول الشحنات الاسلحه
الغربيه الى كيف بدات روسيا في استخدام
اسلحه حديثه ومتطوره وادخالها لقوتها
الناريه في ساحه الحرب لاول مره تقرير
لوزاره الدفاع البريطانيه هكذا ان روسيا
استخدم الطائرات سوخوي 57 المتطوره لاطلاق
الصواريخ بعيده الماده من الاجواء الروسيه
على اهداف اوكرانيا
لكن بما تتميزوا هذه المقاتله هي من الجيل
الخامس لطائرات الاسرع من الصوت ثنائيه
المحرك دخلت الخدمه لاول مره عام 2020 في
القوات الجوف الفضائيه الروسيه تستخدمها
روسيا في تدمير شبكه الدفاع الجوي في
اوكرانيا
لامكانيتها في تنفيذ مهمه متعدده
اكتشاف الاهداف على ماذا اكثر من 400 كلم
قادره على تتبع الستين هدفا في ان واحد
في خطوه تتخذها موسكو للرد على التسليح
الغربي لاوكرانيا ابرزه خطط دعمها بمنظومه
الدفاع الجوي الامريكيه
نشرت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه لقطات المظهر
استخدام المقاتل الصخري 57 صاروخ كروز
الموجه تلفزيونيه ضد اهداف العسكريه في
كيف وتدميرها
عامها الثاني تسعه اوكرانيا لتقويه
دفاعاتها وترسمتها العسكريه للحفاظ على
اراضيها والحد من التقدم الروسي
الغرب بمواصله الحرب
يفوق التوقعات
الى موضوع اخر يستمر توافذ المحتاجين
الايرانيين منذ ليله امس على سجن رجاء شهر
في شمالي ايران لمنع الاعدام محتاجين
اثنين هما محمد برجوني ومحمد قبله وكانت
قوات الامن قد اطلقت النار على متظاهرين
في محيط السجن
امام بوابه السجن تمديدا بعزم السلطات
[موسيقى]
حقوق الانسان
من المتظاهرين
بعد نقلهم الى الزنزانه الانفراديه في سجن
رجالي
قائد الحرس الثوري الايراني وصف
الاحتجاجات في بلاده بان حرب عالميه فيما
وصف المرشد الايراني علي خمين الاحتجاجات
الشعبيه في البلاد بانها خيانه كبيره
لايران ودعاخ من امام الحج من انصاره
مؤسسات الدوله الى التعامل بشكل حازم وجاد
مجددا القول ان الاحتجاجات تقف خلفها
مؤامرات خارجيه هدفها تدمير ايران
الفرنسيه قالت ان النظام الايراني مستمر
في قمع المتظاهرين حيث بات يسمح بتدهور
الوضع الاقتصادي في البلاد لاضعاف
احتجاجات المواطنين
في جاره تقول ان النظام اصدر بدايه الشهر
تحذيرا باعاده بدء مراقبه الحجاب وهو مثال
على الغموض الذي تنتجه السلطات حاله
قرارات معينه فيما يستغل النظام السياسه
العصا والجزره ضد المحتجين في محاوله لخنق
التظاهرات
وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه انا لينا
ايربروك اعلنت من جهتها انها استدعت
السفير الايراني مجددا وابلغته بان اعدام
الشباب المحتاجين لن يمر بدون عواقب
وقالت بيربك ان النظام الذي يقتل الشباب
ويمارس الارهاب ضد الشعب لا مستقبل له
واضافت ان الاجتماع المقبل للاتحاد
الاوروبي سيناقشه اضافه اسماء جديده من
الحرس الثوري
الايرانيه على لائحه العقوبه
وزاره الخارجيه الفرنسيه اصدار القضاء
الايرانيه احكاما بحقوبه الاعدام ضد
مجموعه من المتظاهرين الخارجيه الفرنسيه
شدد ايضا على تنديرها بالاحكام الايرانيه
مرارا وتكرارا علنا ومباشرتا مع شركائها
في الاتحاد الاوروبي الذي تبنى عقوبات ضد
المسؤولين عن القمع العنيف في ايران
مع الان لمزيد من المتابعه الصحفي المتخصص
في الشان الايراني مسعود الفك مسعود اهلا
وسهلا بك هل تعتقد ان التظاهرات في محيط
سجن رجاء شهر في كارج مسعود ستدفع السلطات
الايرانيه الى اعاده النظر في احكام
الاعدام بحق همم هؤلاء الشخصين
املا شيء سيتغير
تحياتي لكم
النظام الايراني
لا يقبل الا بالحل الامني للاحتجاجات الحل
الامني والورقه الوحيده الذي التي يلعبها
النظام الايراني منذ انطلاق الاحتجاجات في
17 سبتمبر الماضي همم لحد الان لم يسمع
لاصوات المحتجين ولا حتى
يعتقد
بامكانيه الوصول الى حل وسط بينه وبين
المحتاجين
سقف المشتجين في في المطالب وصلت الى
المطالبه برحيل النظام والنظام همم يتهم
المحتجين بالعماله والارتباط بقوه اجنبيه
تريد ان تضر الامن القومي الايراني
لا توجد مساحه وسط الان في الوقت الحاضر
في عقليه النظام والعقليه والعقيده
السياسيه التي يؤمن بها ويتمسك بها هذه
العقيده السياسيه تفرض على النظام
الايراني بان اي شخص حتى لو كان ايرانيا
يعارض النظام فهو عميد للاعداء هذه
العقيده السياسيه التي
تابعها النظام
ثوره 1979 دفعت كثيرين من ابناء الثوره
الى النزول من قطار مسعود ما لا يعني بس
السلطات اللي نسمع ما تقول له السلطات
تقول انها لا تقتل ولا تنفذ احكام اعدام
بحق متظاهرين سلميه هي تنفذ احكام اعدام
بحق مدانين
بقتلهم همم افراد من الحرس الثوري خلال
هذه الاحتجاجات وان هذه احكام ينص عليها
القانون الايراني ما رايك بهذا الكلام
لو لو قبلنا جدلا بهذا الكلام هناك مساله
مهمه جدا لماذا لا تسمح السلطات
بالمتهمين الذين تتهممهم بالقتل وهي لديها
اثباتات ووثائق لماذا لا
تعطي فرصه لهم ان يكونوا في محكمه عادله
بحضور محامين
ينتخبهمون ليس المحامين الذي تنتخبوا
السلطه وتفردها على على على
المتهمين هذه هي اكبر خلق للقضاء الايراني
نفسه لماذا لا تزال محاكم الثوره هي التي
تحاكم على طريقه المحاكم همم الميدانيه
هناك لو كان القضاء القضاء عادلا ياخذ بكل
الامور بعين الاعتبار في هذه الحاله نقبل
همم ان يتم محاكمه هؤلاء وفقا للتهم التي
موجهه الي من قبل النظام لا يتم فرض عليهم
محامي من قبل السلطه
ومحاكمات قصيره واعدامات سريعه في حين في
ايران
الان هو يرتبط بالقصاص مثلا يبقى ال ال
المدان لمده سنوات حتى يتم اعدامه الان
يتم الاعتقال المحاكمه والاعدام في وقت
قياسي مسعود السلطات الايرانيه ما زالت
تقول انما يجري مؤامره خارجيه تحركها
واشنطن وحلفائها الاوروبيون للتاثير على
الموقف والسياسه الايرانيه في المنطقه
والعالم ما رايك
هل
الغرب وااا والاوروبيون لديهم هذه القوه
بامكانهم تحريك الشارع الايراني ضد النظام
هذا هذا تناقض يعني هذا النظام هل فقد
شعبيته الى درجه تستطيع الدول الاخرى تحرك
جيل بكامله ضد السلطه اعتقد هذا النظام
يراقب نفسه بهذا بهذا الحديث لا علاقه باي
جهه اجنبيه ان كانت اقليميه ان كانت دوليه
ان كانت اسرائيل الولايات المتحده او
الدول العربيه كما تقول ايران بعض الاحيان
لا علاقه لاحد بما يجري في الداخل الظروف
التي
ناتجه هذه الظروف عن الفقر همم فقدان
الحريات التي وعدت بها ثوره 1979
ايضا
تقليص الحريات الاجتماعيه هي السبب
الرئيسي وراء هذه الاحتجاجات ولا شيء اخر
ساتفي بهذا القدر الصحفي المتخصص في
الشارع الايراني شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه
المشاركه
الشوط الخامس مستمره في ايضا
تايوان تهدد باحدث تدريبات عسكريه الصينيه
قرب الجزيره والولايات المتحده تفعل ما
يعرف بخطه الفلبين
اهلا بكم من جديد الى نشره الخامسه من
العربيه تنتشروا الشرطه البرازيليه بكثافه
لتنفيذ قرار بفضي اعتصام لانصار الرئيس
السابق
في برازيليا فيما اقدمت السلطات على نشر
المئات من قوات الشرطه والجيش في الشوارع
الرئيسيه واباب المقار الحكومي ذلك في
محاوله لبسط الامن ووقف عمليات التخريب
التي طالت مبنى المحكمه العليا والكونغرس
والقصر الرئاسي واصفارات عن تدمير اعمال
الفنيه وسرقه النسخه الاصليه من الدستور
بالاضافه الى الاستلاف على بنادق من مكتب
الامن الرئاسي
الهدوء عاده تدريجيا الى البرازيل اثرى
مشهد اندراميا غير مسبوق في تاريخ
الديمقراطيه البرازيليه وعلى الفور بدات
السلطات التحقيق في اسوا هجوم شعبي على
مؤسسات الدوله
القصه بدات اجتياح عشرات الالاف من انصار
الرئيس البرازيلي اليمني السابق جير
بورسونارو قلب العاصمه بعد اسبوع واحد فقط
من تنصيبه
رئيسا للبلاد وارتدى المحتاجون قمصان
منتخب كره القدم وحمل واعلام البرازيل قبل
اقتحامهم مراكز الحكم الثلاثه الكونجرس
والمحكمه العليا كما حاصلوا القصر الرئاسي
في العاصمه قبل اقتحامه والعبث بمقتنياته
وبعد ساعات طردت الشرطه المحتاجين من
مؤسسات الدوله واعتقلت العشرات منهم
تلك التطورات دفعت بالرئيس الجديد الى وصف
الاحتجاجات بالانقلاب كما فرض اجراءات
الاستثنائيه لاستعاده النظام
الذي تولى منصبه في الاول من يناير حمل
الرئيس السابق بورسونارو مسؤوليه الاحداث
باثارته حمله وصفها بالمزومه بشان تزوير
الانتخابات
بدوره ومن فلوريدا الامريكيه التي وصلها
قبل يومين من انتهاء فتره رئاسه رفض
بورسونال ووصف المظاهرات بانها سلميه
الديمقراطيه لكنه اعتبر ان اقتحام المباني
الحكوميه يمثل تجاوزا احدث لاقت ردود فعل
عالميه ممدده اعتبرتها تهديدا للديمقراطيه
كما احيت بتفاصيلها ما حدث في واشنطن قبل
عامين يوم اقتحم الانصار الرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب مبنى الكونجرس حنان
المصري العربي
[موسيقى]
الصور التي ترد الان لي من برازيليه من
العاصمه البرازيليه البرازيليه بعد فضل
الاعتصام من قبل قوات الامن البرز-
البرازيليه لانصار الرئيس السابق
والسينارو وعمليات فك الخيم في هذا
الاعتصام بالطبع بالامس كان انصار الرئيس
السابق والسونارو قد اقتحموا مبنى
الكونجرس والقصر همم الرئاسي
وجرت عمليات وفر واقتحامات وصدمات مع همم
الشرطه همم اليوم المعلومات تقول ان هؤلاء
انسحبوا وان ال همم القوات الامن هل
البرازيليه قامت
بفك خيامهم واعتصماتهم في محيط القصر
الرئاسي في العاصمه البرازيليه البرازيليه
بالطبع الرئيس لا لا لو سيلفا هو الان همم
في العاصمه البرازيليه كان بالامس همم في
ساو باولو ولكن همم عاد همم وسط هذه
الاخبار واكد ان الاوضاع مسيطر تحت
السيطره خلال تفقده همم للقصر الرئاسي في
برنسيسيه بالطبع سنكون بعد قليل مع ضيفنا
همم من برازيلي لاطلاعنا همم على همم كل
هذه همم التطورات السيد هاني درسي ولكن
همم الدرس الثاني ولكن همم حتى الساعه
الاتصال لم يتامل معه سنكون معه بعد قليل
اذا انضم الى منذ قليل
الصحفي هاني الدرساني هو معي من العاصمه
البرازيليه البرازيليه لوفاتنا باي جديد
هاني اهلا وسهلا بك كيف هي الاوضاع في
العاصمه البرازيلي هل الامور
تنحو نحو الهدوء الشامل ام لا انصار
الرئيس مرسينارو لن يسلم ابدا بالهزيمه ان
صح التعبير
الاجواء بشكل عام شبه طبيعيه الى حده الله
همم تراجعت عدد اعداد المتظاهرين
المتواجدين طبعا الحكومه قد وضعت حواجز
اسمديه قد قامت به
الكثير من الطرقات كثير من التحويلات داخل
المدينه الحركه ليست طبيعيه بالنسبه للمره
او حتى للع طيب هذا الشيء يقلل من تواجد
وتحركات المناصرين لبوسوناريا الان انا
موجود
برازيلي حيث كانت هنالك الكثير من الخيم
الاحتجاجيه التي نصبت قبل فتره امام هذا
البناء قامت قوات الجيش في ازاله هذه
الخيم وقامت
نقل المحتاجين الى مكان اخر عدد محتاج
نقله
لا لا همم تجميع انبعا 40 حافله تم نقلب
الى منطقه ابعد
من المكان نحن نتواجه المتجهدين فيها طيب
هاني ماذا يريد ان صار الرئيس السابق قل
سينارو من يقودهم في هذه الاحتجاجات
ويعني هل ما جرى هو بروفا ستستكمل في
الايام المقبله ام لا يجب تكبير الحجر
يعني هذا حجم ما جرى
في الحقيقه مطالبهم واضحه مطلبهم الرئيسي
هو الغاء النتائج الانتخابيه وعدم
اعتمادها وكان لهم مطلق اخر بدا منذ صدور
ان نتائج انتخابيه في تدخل الجيش لاستلام
السلطه واستلامي مقاليد ال- ال- ال- الحكم
في همم طبعا في البرازيل من يديرهم
طبعا الحقيقه داخل الدوله حتى داخل
الحكومه الحاليه همم نصف الشعب قد صوت
لبوسناريو اذا لديه قائد شعبيه ايضا كبيره
ولديهم اصوات ولديهم قدره على
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي لديهم اشخاص
مؤثرين جدا في وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
يتم دعوه المطهرين للتجمع من من خلالهم
الفيسبوك قبل قليل الاستجابه لطلبه بعمليه
همم الحج من الفيديوهات التي تؤيد للخروج
والتظاهر ضد حكومه
وقد نرى ايضا اجابا من تويتر مشابهه لما
حدث مع ترامب قد يحدث ذلك في ايقاف حساب
تويتر الخاص
ولكن بعد تكهنات تقوم بانه قد يلجا تويتر
الى هذا الاجرام طيب هاني هل يبدو لك
الرئيس لولا ده سيلفا ممسكا تماما بزمان
الامور وان هو لا عوده الى الوراء ولن يتم
اعاده النظر بنتائج الانتخابات يعني هذا
قرار مجرم بالنسبه اليه
100% هذا صحيح هذا يعني هذه الرساله وجه
صباح اليوم من خلال اجتماعي الرئيس دولا
بالموزراء واجتماعه بالنواب وايضا بي
رؤساء بعض الولايات هنالك تاييد تام من
قبل الجميع القواعد السياسيه في الفيلات
سواء كانوا
عارضين
الديمقراطيه البرازيليه هي التي وجدت
اليها الضربه مباشره بالحقيقه الامر الى
امسك عقلك ان تخوف لدى الجميع بان تهتز
هذه القاعده الديمقراطيه في الدوله ويتحول
الامر الى فوضع عارمه ولكن الصوره العامه
بان بالفعل حكومه دا سيلفا اول وولد
دارسين يعني ممسكين باسماء الامر الى غايه
اللحظه هنالك دعم ايضا عسكري ودعم لقبل
الوحدات الشرطه تم ارسالهم من قبل
الولايات المجاوره للبرازيلي لهذا الشيء
يعطي تايدا وشرعيه ايضا هل الاحتكاكات
يعني سواء بين انصار فول سونار وانصار
لولا سيلفا مقتصره على العاصمه البرازيليه
ام لا في مدن اخرى شهدت احتكاكات ومواجهات
باختصار
توجد ايضا مظاهرات في مدن اخرى في مدينه
كانت هنالك احتجاجات ومحاولات من قبل
انصار بولسنوري الاقتحام شركه بترو براس
وهي الشركه النقطيه الوطنيه همم وايضا
هنالك ايضا احتكاكات كانت في سامباولو في
بعض المدن الاخرى هنالك هذا الامر سوف
يستمر صراحه لايام كثيره ولاسابيع كثيره
بدا منذ اشهر وسوف يستمر بعد هذا الحدث
الكبير الذي حصل في البرازيل يوم امس طيب
طيب هاني وانت تتحدث خبر عاجل الرئيس
البرازيلي والمحكمه العليا والكونغولي
يصنفون همم ما جرى بانها اعمال ارهابيه
شكرا لك من العاصمه البرازيليه البرازيليه
هاني الدرساني على كل هذه المتابعه
اذان مكتب الرئاسه في تايوانه تدريبات
العسكريه الاخيره التي اجرتها الصين
بالقرب من الجزيره قائلان ان السلامه
والاستقرار في مضيق تايوان والمنطقه
مسؤوليه مشتركه لكل من تايب وبيكين وزاره
الدفاع التايوانيه افادت برصد 57 طائره
صينيه خلال تدريبات بكين العسكريه قرب
الجزيره كما اوضح بيان المكتب الرئاسي ان
موقفه تايوان واضح للغايه من حيث انها لم
تصاعد الصراعات او تثير الخلافات لكنها
ستدافع عن سيادتها وامنيها
قيد القوات الامريكيه في اليابان
[موسيقى]
سيسمح لنا
القوات الامريكي
[موسيقى]
تحديده مواقع تقديم الدعم واجراء وعمليات
المستضعف
عمليات في اليابان والفلبين ومواقع اخرى
بينها خطه الفلبين منح نقطه نفوذ من عشر
قواعد
درجات الحراره المرتفعه بشكل قياسيه هذا
الشتاء في اوروبا ان عكست اجابه حيث خففت
من ازمه الطاقه وتبدو مستقره حتى الان رغم
استمرار العمليه العسكريه الروسيه في
المانيا تقول ان امدادات الغاز لهذا
الشتاء امنه ويجب التركيز على الشتاء
المقبل بينما تستمر بريطانيا في معاناه
ارتفاع اسعار الغاز متوقعه عن استمرارها
لعامين او ثلاثه اعوام المقبله
يبدو ان شتاء اوروبا هذا العام الدافئه
بعض الشيء جاء في صالحها فكان الاوروبيون
يخشون لاشهر من التجمد هذا الشتاء بسبب
ازمه طاقه الناجمه عن الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه ولم يتوقعوا حينها موجه حاره
العلميه تقول لان 5 10 دوله اوروبيه على
الاقل شهدت درجات حراره قياسيه الاسبوع
الماضي وامتدت لمناطق من فرنسا الى
المانيا وبلجيكا وهولندا
فالعاصمه البولنديه وارسو التي تتمتع بسجل
المناخي يعود تاريخه الى مئه عام حتى مطر
رقم القياسي لدرجه الحراره في يناير باكثر
من خمس درجات مئويه ويعود ذلك بشكل عام
الى ارتفاع حراره الغلاف الجوي والمحيطات
حول العالم المانيا بدورها افادت بان
لديها ما يكفي من الغاز خلال موسم الشتاء
الحالي دون التعرض لخطر امدادات الطوارئ
وفقا منظم الالمانيه كلاوس مولر وان
تركيزه ينصب الان على الشتاء القادم مؤكدا
ايضا ان مخزون الغاز في المانيا تفوق
مستوياته حاجزه 90% اما في بريطانيا رجح
الخبراء من انه من غير المتوقع ان تنخفض
فواتير الغاز خلال العامين او الثلاثه
اعوام المقبله على الرغم من انخفاض اسعار
الغاز بالجمله الى مستويات لم تشهدها منذ
ما قبل الازمه الاوكرانيه انخفاض اسعار
الغاز بالجمله لم ينعكس على الفواتير
الاستهلاكيه للافراد حيث يشتري الموردون
الكثير من الغاز مقدما باسعار قد تكون
اعلى من العاده وفقه صحيفه تمرر
البريطانيه هذا عدا عن استمرار ارتفاع
اسعار الكهرباء في بريطانيا بثلاث مرات
مقارنه بالغاز الطبيعي ما يجعل حتى
الاجهزه الكهربائيه لتدفئه المنازل وشحن
السيارات باهضه الثمن رشا خياط العربيه
النشاط الخامس مستمره فيها ايضا
كاتبه السيره الذاتيه للملك تشونس كثرن
ماير تعتبروا نشره كتاب الامير هاري
تهديدا لنظام الملكي في بريطانيا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم جديد يسعى جهاز الصحه العامه في
انجلترا الى بدء اخراج الاف المرضى من
المستشفيات في الاسابيع القليله المقبله
في محاولات لتوفير اسره تشتد الحاجه اليها
خلال احد اصعب فصول الشتاء على الاطلاق
ويتم حاليا علاجه المرضى في الممرات فيما
تقف سيارات الاسعاف في طوابيره خارج
المستشفيات لنقل المرضى الى اقسام الطوارئ
حيث يواجه جهاز الصحه الذي تديره الدوله
والذي يوفره رعايه مجانيه لجميع السكان
يواجه ضغوطن بعد سنوات من التراجع النسبي
للاستثمارات وتداعيات رائحه كورونا واضراب
العاملين الاساسيين في مجال الصحه بسبب
تدني الاجور
الهدف عزاء المشاهدين من اخراج بعض المرضى
من اماكن الى اماكن اخرى هو احياء لاسلوب
استخدمه جهاز الصحه في انجلترا اثناء
الجائحه وذلك لتوفير اكبر عدد ممكن من
الاسره لمرضى كوفي نايتين وقد اعتبر ستيف
بارك لوزير الصحه ان هذا الشتاء يمثل
تحديا كبيرا لجهاز الصحه العامه من حيث
الضغوط الهائله بسبب قبض والانفلونزا
بالاضافه الى معالجه العمليات المتراكمه
والاضرابات المقبله
وسيحدد بارك لي امام البرلمان اجراءات
اخرى لتقليل الضغوط التي تواجه جهاز الصحه
فيما اظهرت احصائيات اخرى ان 9 اسره من
اصل 10 في المستشفيات كانت مشغوله في
الاسبوع الاخير من العام الماضي
معي من لندن مراسل العربيه مصطفى زارو
مصطفى اهلا وسهلا بك جديد المشهد مشهد
المستشفيات في بريطانيا وهل الامور بهذا
السوء وبهذه القسوه التي نسمع عنها ام لا
لا يجب تكبير حجم الامور بهذا الشكل
الوضع مقلق للغايه الطالب بسبب اا يعني
ازدحام المستشفيات وايضا الان كما ذكرت
بان الحكومه تنظر في محاوله تفريغ بعض همم
الاسره في المستشفيات
لتوفيرها لاولئك الذين ينتظرون دخول
المستشفيات الخاصه لمن يعانون من امراض
مزمنه همم هؤلاء الذين تنوي الحكومه همم
نقلهم الى دور الرعايه يستطيعون الحصول
على همم
المتابعه الطبيه من قبل هؤلاء الذين
يعملون في تلك الدواء ولكن ال- ال- السعه
الاستعابيه همم لهذه المستشفيات يعني في
حدود تقريبا 100,000 سرير وبالتالي كانت
هناك ضغوطات كبيره وخاصه مع ارتفاع حالات
كورونا وايضا امراض الانفلونزا بالاضافه
الى ايضا الحمى القرمزيه همم هذه الامراض
الموسميه الشتويه ض بشكل كبير على قطاع
الصحه الذي يعاني اصلا من نقص في كوادره
بالاضافه الى ان ما يقار من 10,000 همم
يعني عامل في قطاع الصحه حتى نهايه
الاسبوع الماضي كانوا يعانون من امراض
فيروس وبالتالي هذا اثر بشكل سلبي على
تقديم خدمات الصحيه للمرضى مصطفى لماذا
تبدو الحكومه وكانها عاجزه عن مواكبه همم
ما يجري وهل من خطط وضعتها للسيطره على
هذا الوطن
السبب الوحيد والوجي وهو بسبب عدم ضخها
المليارات منذ سنوات طويله وبالتالي بدات
تضخ يعني عشرات المليارات في هذا القطاع
ولكن يعني هناك نقص في الكوادر الطبيه
بالاضافه الى ان هناك مطالبه بزياده
الاجور لهؤلاء الذين يعملون في قطاع الصحه
واليوم فشلت المفاوضات التي عقدها وزير
الصحه باركلز مع عدد من مسؤولي النقابات
سواء الذين يمثلون اطقم الاسعاف او
الممرضين او اولئك الذين يعملون في قطاعات
اخرى داخل هذه المستشفيات وبالتالي هذا
يندير بان الاضطرابات يعني اعيد جدولتها
وبالتالي هذه المفاوضات لم ااه تخرج او لم
تحل النزاع بين النقابه والحكومه وبالتالي
نتوقع ان تكون هذه الاضرابات يعني ربما
اكبر من شهدناه من قبل حسب تحذ من عدد من
نقابه وبالتالي هذا واقع يعني مرير تواجه
الحكومه وايضا ولكن يريدون الحصول على
علاج في احد المستشفيات مصطفى البعض يعتبر
حتى قراتها في عدد من الصحف انه ما يجري
همم من ازمه في المستشفيات الان هو احدث
تجليات لبريكست هؤلاء يصفون السيء التي
بدا التداعياتها تظهر على المجتمع على
البريطاني هل يعني فعلا بدانا نشهد
تداعيات هذا البريكزيت وما يجري الان هو
حتى تجلياته
من دون شك طالب بان البريكزيت له تداعياته
يعني منذ ان ان تم الاعلان عن خروج
فيتامين الاتحاد الاوروبي كانت هناك
العديد من الجنسيات الاوروبيه داخل
الاتحاد الاوروبي لاني قرروا العوده الى
بلدانهم للعمل من هناك وهذا همم بالاضافه
الى ان حتى اولئك البريطانيين الذين
يعملون في مختلف قطاع الصحه وقطاعات اخرى
فضل ربما الهجره الى بلدان اخرى ولا سيما
في استراليا التي تقدم عروضا مغريه لهؤلاء
الكوادر البريطانيه وبالتالي يعني همم
مثلا بالنسبه لقطاع الصحه وخاصه الممرضين
يعني رواتبهم يزيد عن ما يقارب من ما
يتقاضونه هنا وايضا الساعات العامه اللي
هي اقل بكثير وبالتالي العروض المغريه
ربما جلبت العديد من البريطانيين الى دول
مثل استراليا بالاضافه الى ان
هناك يعني همم تراجع وعدم جديه يعني مل
هذه الوظائف الشاغره هناك ما يقارب من 133
وظيفه شاغره في قطاع الصحه منها 47 وظيفه
للممرضين وبالتالي هذا يعني عدد اضخم كيف
يمكن ان تملا هذه الوظائف في في يعني في
همم وقت خلال اشهر ربما سيكون من الصعب
جيد من الاردن مراسل العربيه مصطفى زارو
دائما شكرا لك مصطفى على كل هذه الحاطه من
العاصمه البريطانيه
السعوديه الامير محمد بن سلمان
لصندوق الاستثمارات العامه ليصبح واحده من
المشاريع الفريده من نوعها على مستوى
العالم
وتضم منطقه الدرعيه السعوديه
المدرج على قائمه اليونسكو للتراث العالمي
على ضوء نشر كتاب سبير للامير هاري والذي
يركز على الخلافات الشخصيه بين افراد
العائله المالكه في بريطانيا قالت المحلله
وكاتبه السيره الذاتيه للملكه
العنصريه والثروه التي تمتلكها العائله
الملكيه البريطانيه قد ينهي قبول العامه
بالنظام الملكي في البلاد وبحسب صحيفه
الجاردن البريطانيا
فان النشره المبكر لكتاب الامير هاري له
نتائج كارثيه ويهدد النظام الملكي في
بريطانيا
الذي شنه الامير هاري على سلوك العائله
المالكه في كتابه
[تصفيق]
اطيب التحيات والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته
[موسيقى]